Let's switch gears and test our model
out against the validation sample
to see how well it holds up
against its independent data.
So what we're going to do is
have the same model that we
already built up before in
that decision tree model, but
now we're going to plug in
the model comparison tool.
We're going to configure this model
comparison tool the same way that we
did before.
So the model object goes
into the M side and
the validation sample
goes into the D side.
The positive class, yet
again, is going to be yes,
then I'm going to bring in a browse
tool, after this R, a report output.
What we're able to see in
this model comparison report
is that the overall accuracy is
that 89% which is quite strong,
but it is slightly less than
the logistic regression model.
What I'm able to see
the confusion matrix yet again.
How many yeses were predicted yeses,
and how many nos were
actually predicted nos.
So yet again it seems like the yeses
were a little more difficult to predict
than the nos.
This is probably because we have many
more no values than yes values, and
yet again, we're going again to these
diagnostic plots a little bit later.
But overall,
this seems to be a very good model at
predicting this validation data set.
Now the question is, which model
should we use in production to predict
who is actually likely to respond
to the marketing campaign?